a metro officer finds himself on the
wrong side of the law tonight police say
caleb rogers was caught robbing the rio
and he could even be linked to other
armed robberies and he went before a
judge this morning the 8 news now
i-team's vanessa murphy first broke this
story at 8 news newsnow dot com she is
here live in studio with the very latest
denise and brian a judge set the bail
for officer caleb rogers at 250 thousand
dollars if he can post bond he'll be on
high level electronic monitoring and
banned from the las vegas strip the
judge this morning pointing to the
violence rogers is accused of
he was brandishing a firearm threatening
multiple people on multiple occasions
that he will shoot in that he has again
metro police say one of their own
officer caleb rogers tried to rob the
rio casino early sunday morning as first
reported by the 8 news now i-team rogers
may be linked to two other casino
robberies at red rock on november 12 and
at aliante on january 6. police had
previously released these images asking
for the public's help to identify the
suspect similar
ammos similar walking appears to be the
same person that metro is currently
investigating according to the
department rogers has been an officer
since 2015 and he was assigned to the
community policing division at bolden
area command the i-team found court
documents from a 2020 divorce where he
lists multiple loans including from
money tree and dollar loan center his
public defender pointing to several
factors including his roots in the
community no criminal history and
previously stable employment but his
work as a police officer may not help
his case in court the fact that the
defendant in this case has been trained
as a police officer at the expense of
the county and has betrayed that trust
by engaging in criminal conduct
rogers is suspended without pay he faces
four felony charges including assault
with a deadly weapon the head of the
police union says the union will not
represent rogers since the alleged
crimes happened off duty and he says if
the allegations are true the union is
disgusted and disappointed by the
actions of one rogue officer